the european union's general affairs
council has kicked off serbia's eu
membership talks with the first official
round of negotiations to start next
month
they adopted negotiation framework for
serbia that means we started de facto
negotiations
and we are looking forward to the first
intergovernmental conference which will
take place in january
like all candidates for membership
serbia will have to meet eu standards in
35 policy areas or chapters the process
can take several years
in a broader look at eu enlargement the
ministers also said that granting
albania's request for candidate status
was just a question of time and that
this could happen in june
the former yugoslav republic of
macedonia's hopes of beginning accession
talks will be considered again next year
the ministers also debated a review of
the european external action service
they gave their full support to
recommendations that could be
implemented in the short term like
boosting cooperation between eu
delegations and those of the member
states and acknowledge the need to
improve the effectiveness of common
security and defence policy missions
the ministers also had a working lunch
with president herman van rompuy to
discuss preparations for this week's
european council in brussels eu leaders
are set to discuss defence policy and
europe's defence industry economic
policy the fate of would-be immigrants
in the mediterranean as well as
relations with ukraine and the central
african republic